am samstagnachmittag trifft das par
olympic team austria wieder in wien ein
mit dem favoriten verspätung mehr als
geplant denn nach der landung wird noch
kurz im leeren flieger gefeiert
wirklich schön dann auch die ankunft der
sechs errungenen medaillen und deren
träger gold und bronze medaillengewinner
weiter ab länger weiß über die vielen
mütter und väter eines solchen erfolgs
das beginnt wieder bei meiner familie
geht über meine eltern mein
freundeskreis
hier bis zu meinem persönlichen betreuer
team und vor allem auch natürlich diese
ganz ganz wichtigen organisationen in
österreich das österreichische
bundesheer die sporthilfe zum beispiel
der österreichische behindert wird
verbannt da gibt es ganz ganz viele
menschen die im hintergrund einfach
arbeiten und einfach ein teil dieser
medaille sind das bei den handbikern
jeder der drei medaillengewinner gleich
zweimal zu schlagen kann mag für manchen
überraschend seien nicht für
doppelsitzer gewinner thomas frühwirth
denn in tokio hat er erst sage man
irgend ein ganzer sandsack haben ja auch
doppel vize weltmeister geworden war und
ist das wieder abrufen können in tokio
ist alles anders wir
selbstverständlichkeit gewesen dafür
für den zweifachen gewinner alexander
krieg ist sein erfolg in tokio erst der
anfang die motivation der jungen 150
prozent gestiegen
medaillen mangel 2024 wird es für die
österreichischen handbiker mit
sicherheit keinen geben denn diese
werden aus recycelten mit telefonen
hergestellt
vorbildlich wenn die abda ist
heute handys gelegt worden und und aus
diesem maß an die materialien gewonnen
worden und ja also
bekommt natürlich ein ehrenplatz bei mir
zu hause und riesig riesig stolz darauf
so gesehen ist ab jetzt jeder der drei
und der 290 erreichbar